guys can we push the meeting an hour
what's going on some guy handcuffed
himself to a pipe in my office because
he wouldn't put a copy of Twilight in
the Time Capsule damn it again
no you're too important for me until one
of your own gets attacked I just feel
like there's more we can do to keep the
park safe oh you think you know how to
do my job well you might not be so
confident once you've walked a mile on
my size
sevens kind of small feet actually seven
is a worldwide average
boom you guys
ready oh boy yeah okay we're ready I'm
going to show you guys all the problems
we've been facing I'm going to show you
that we've been doing everything we can
I'm looking forward to working together
Carl and after that I'm going to show
you this log I found it's got like 50
worms on
it I call it worm
log yeah I've always been a bit of an
Outdoorsman uh when I was a kid my
parents used to make me hang out in the
backyard a lot and just run around till
I got tired but if there's any criminals
out there watching I never get
tired and ladies
too this thing is a mess we used to have
three carts actually the first one got
pushed into the creek by some kids the
second one raccoons got on to there was
urine everywhere and the third one was
recently stolen what's this one this is
the second one the raccoon piss one
all right so welcome to animal control
let me show you around those are some
chairs that's a cat or possum oh this is
a napkin where I wrote down a cool name
for a dog bark
Obama right is that what's happening
here oh yo yeah we found this bird
outside we tried to turn it into a work
whistle like in the beginning of the
Flintstones tougher than a look though
we have a massive pest problem in this
town and it's because the animal Control
Department has been disaster at catching
animals they're great at ingesting and
selling marijuana this place is a
miserable suckhole run by two pothead
losers it's completely and utterly
mismanaged thanks it does seem to be
very poorly run but we've only been here
for 2 minutes there may be a method to
their Madness there's more than one way
to skin a cat four there's four ways to
skin a cat
ready what is this coyote trap dude God
this hurts yeah we got like a huge
verment problem I mean we meaning to
call somebody about you know nobody get
on the phone you're the people you would
be calling that is so
trippy you're fired you're fired the
whole department is fired ow this hurts
this was one of my running feet yo let's
go to Jamaica no we should go to Jamaica
oh is that what you
said and combined they have sold more
than a 100 million copies worldwide now
have you seen any of the Twilight movies
no I have not then let me describe them
to you shot for shot movie number one
Twilight we slow slowly pan up over a
Mossy log to see a deer drinking crystal
clear water okay Kelly this time capsule
isn't just a barrel full of stuff that
people like it's about life and ponie at
this moment in time and there is nothing
in Twilight that is specific to Pon E I
disagree okay that the town of Forks
Washington is exactly like Pon except
for the climate and the vampires I'm
sorry I have to say no I beg you to
reconsider and I'm going to have to ask
you to leave and I'm going to have to do
this
okay buddy time is up give us the keys
they're hidden somewhere very far away
then we're going to have to cut you
loose why I'm not doing anything wrong
yes you are you're trespassing well the
fact remains this is perfectly legal no
it's not you're trespassing look I I
really don't want to cause any trouble
but I am not going to leave until you
put Twilight in the Time Capsule this
muscle-headed Stormtrooper doesn't scare
me go ahead go ahead
Hardy no no please no no no no no no get
away me I'm very scared of
[Music]
you howdy neighbors welcome to human
Farm here's your animal feed please
don't feed the
animals wow this is really really cool I
like the statement it's making that you
know know we're all in cages in a way
yeah it's actually about death and the
city yeah I see that
now hi
Orin I think we should do more stuff
like this you know I think Pon needs an
amazing arts program maybe you should
just drop everything and coordinate it
I'm not stupid what is that supposed to
mean it means that the only reason you
brought me here is to distract me from
the dog park you hate this show I love
this show what's your favorite part the
heavy-handedness you know what I have to
go talk to councilman Jam right now why
are you talking to councilman Jam
because I told him about the dog park
idea and he loves it he thinks it's a
great idea he's going to support my
motion at the city council meeting
tomorrow and he gave me a really cool
Dental mirror to check out my mullers
our dispute aside you should be careful
with Jam he's a snake I'm telling you
yeah like I should trust you out of all
people right
[Music]
now moo moo quiet weirdo aren't you
supposed to be a sheep no you are shut
up Joan on behalf of the entire city
congratulations I do want to apologize
for not being able to accommodate some
of your requests for example we couldn't
get a bottle of Chateau Marmont because
it's a hotel in Los Angeles not a wine
well did you at least get Buddy Holly to
sing no because he's been famously dead
for 60 years what hi Joan hi my name is
April and I'm your biggest fan and I
pretty much hate everyone will you sign
your ninth Memoir for me well it would
be my pleasure you said your name was
Glenn yes I did that's pretty Joan has
always been kind of a train wreck but
the last 3 years she's gone off the deep
end she did a string of shows from rehab
Victoria Herzog you were a successful
attorney from Wilmington Delaware then
you hit rock bottom this is supposed to
be anonymous she once gave every member
in her audience a car one car that they
all had to fight for oh and last year
she did a show where she called All of
her ex-boyfriends while sitting on a
washing machine well Eric if you didn't
give it to me then who did I love her so
much I hope she's my real mom you know
they claim that smoking is bad for you
but is there any medical evidence to
back that up great point so the sweds
foundation has really accomplished a lot
recently our Healthcare outreach program
has reduced pink eye in the rural
community by
30% to 70% snooze you guys ever been fox
hunting I have my own foxes flown in
from Russia we drug them pretty heavily
so they can't get very far in fact
mostly they just flop around on the
ground makes it easier to just walk up
and
bow stupid foxes it's deeply erotic that
sounds amazing we should go hunting
sometime I'd love to I could bust out my
Ralph Lauren fall 2010 collection CED it
in 2012 clearance rack wear whatever you
want as long as it's not too bright or
reflective you know I want you blending
in to the surroundings how fast can you
run I think that guy wants to hunt me
hello sir we're sober we would like to
get tattoos in our bodies cuz we love
each other tattoos this is a pawn shop
but yeah sure I can do
that is going to happen look what he's
doing he's breaking pen this is the idea
of the century right here ow come
here
can I ask you a question are we the
cutest couple you've ever seen nope okay
you want the long needle or the short
needle doesn't matter can't find a short
needle long needle it is I have a big
idea I want a portrait of Elanor
Roosevelt Tastefully done and then she
has a very classy tattoo of Pat benitar
on her arm and that's very subtle no
scratch that scratch all that just right
Ben you have anything to numb the pain
sure take a scoop out of the peel
bucket okay you said you wanted mou
Queen hi I'm Donna oh that is the
perfect name for you I love it never
change it wasn't GNA you're Craig right
yes I hate that name so boring sound
like someone's cousin Craig Craig want
to be a Spanish man named Terrence but
that didn't
happen okay so here's my list of Duties
I'm basically the office manager how
about you oh I did everything everything
I carried the the Eagleton department on
my shoulders for years and I loved every
second of it you don't even
know I guess we can make a switch to
Bermuda grass it's only 80 cents more
per square foot what give me givee give
me you want me to put Bermuda grass in a
continental climate that's a six on the
Buford scale in a park with zero
drainage I want Kentucky Bluegrass I
want a 10% discount and I want you to
apologize to my best friend
Donna yeah hi is there and I'm just
guessing here some kind of
medication that you maybe need a lot of
and have taken none of or maybe too much
of today oh I have I have a medical
condition all right it's called caring
too much and it's
incurable also I have
eczema